[Musique]
gagné l'Angleterre à tout prix et par
n'importe quel moyen
depuis les années 90 des milliers de
migrants vers Calais en 2002 en fermant
le centre d'accueil de Sangatte Nicolas
Sarkozy ministre de l'Intérieur français
régler le problème raté
le soir il sert dans les rues dorment
dans les bois ou encore dans les hangars
qui joue je te le port beaucoup se cache
car les contrôles policiers sont très
fréquent
certains sont renvoyées dans leur pays
d'autre part en centre de rétention mais
la plupart sont relâchés des centaines
de migrants laissés à l'abandon qui se
regroupent dans les bois autour de la
ville malgré les températures glaciales
entre ironiquement et
je ne suis pas ce sont les animaux qui
vivent dans la jungle
des animaux
dans la jungle de Calais environ donc
clandestins ils vivent dans 2009 année
où le premier démantèlement est ordonné
policier gendarme
grand près de Calais
migrants qui pleurait qui allait pas ce
qu'ils veulent pas partir façon c'est
très bien qu'il va revenir ils vont
revenir et plus nombreux de 700 migrants
en 2009 il passe tu as 6000 ans 2015 la
jungle de Calais devient temps-ci le
plus grand bidonville d'Europe
peu à peu les constructions en dur
remplace les tente de fortune une petite
ville de 6000 personnes divisé en
quartier pour chaque nationalité
la situation devient ingérable et c'est
scène se multiplient le camion roule à
près de 90 km heure des migrants essaie
de refermer la porte le camion s'arrête
les premiers clandestin sortant tout ils
sont plus de 40 en 2016 la jungle passe
le seuil des 10000 migrants l'état
ordonne un nouveau démantèlement dans ce
quartier Eaux-Vives est une majorité de
soudanais les abris ont été abandonné
parfois dans la précipitation
si la jungle a été démantelé des
migrants envoyé en centre d'accueil le
problème n'a pas été réglée aujourd'hui
selon les estimations de la préfecture
et des associations les migrants serai
toujours entre 700 et 1500 à Calais
toujours candidat à la traversée de la
Manche et à n'importe quel prix
[Musique]